life has been an uphill struggle for
Jack chippy Orca the son of immigrants
he lives in the poor Paris suburb of
saint-denis one of the underprivileged
areas known as the bomb view he faces
stigma yet he's fought his way up and
been accepted at one of the country's
most prestigious engineering schools
without any help from politicians I
wasn't even expecting them to help me
succeed politics is like a reality TV
show where they're playing chess instead
of trying to help us things couldn't
have been more different for Benjamin de
carga lay he was born in an affluent
part of Paris into a wealthy family that
could afford to send him to the very
best schools he said people here have
different expectations of their
politicians Connecticut easier when
you're from a well-off area your aim is
to stand on your own two feet we try to
pass entry exams for good schools and
get good government jobs we just want to
work our way up in the ball you it seems
people need to rely more on the
government to help them they think the
state owes them something here in
wealthy areas we think the state doesn't
owe us anything at all and yet even the
wealthiest trust in politicians has been
shaken especially since their candidate
Francois fian was hit by financial
scandal many of them now back the
centrist Emmanuel macron it's not as if
we feel closer to our politicians
there's a gray area even we don't
understand and that makes us angry in
that sense we're the same as people from
the baño even if we might vote for the
other side of the political spectrum do
you feel about it would it take two
worlds very far apart but they do
sometimes come into contact Jack and
Benjamin are friends they go to the same
school both feel they've learned
something from each other Jack em Jack
has reminded me that right-wing
politicians often forget to talk about
problems in the bolyar because very few
people there vote for them so how can
these politicians then claim to
represent everybody
muzaffer in bridging the ocean fewer
left and right-wing policies can't solve
all the country's problems anymore maybe
it's time for someone like Emmanuel
macron who combines right-wing economic
policies with left-wing social policies
both Jack and Benjamin hope macro will
beat his far-right opponent marine lepen
and that that could finally bring their
two worlds closer together